thank you
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
Maverick billionaire Brian Johnson says
he's the real-life Benjamin Button with
30 doctors thousands of pills millions
of dollars he claims he's made his body
five years younger tonight he'll tell me
how and why I'm an All-Star panel of
age-defying experts will also debate it
can we should we turn back time
[Music]
from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored
well good evening they're welcome to
Pace Morgan on census it's a special
edition tonight and a really special one
everyone's getting older but let's be
honest none of us wants to once you're
old enough to drive and buy a proper
drink it's a slow but inexorable tumbled
on a very big and often pretty torturous
Hill aches multiply hangovers intensify
energy levels recede as fast as your
hairline and the number of things to
look forward to and dream of decline as
we all gradually and reluctantly just
run out of Road well time is Kinder to
some of us and others even at the same
age but we're all going to die that is
an irrefutable fact and whether you
believe in an afterlife or not there's a
premium on making the best of a time we
have and the people we love humans have
understood that for as long as
civilization has existed and we've
thought a long and often fruitless war
against Father Time ancient Greeks
plastered their faces were crocodile
dung victorians rinched their hair in
Orange onion juice one Hungarian Noble
woman bathed in virginal blood
thankfully the methods have changed to
try and arrest the aging process but the
aspiration Remains the Same 70 billion
dollars a year is spent on face filling
lip Plumping nose grafting and other
plastic enhancements for the sagging
torso billions more is spent on Research
into things like biohacking a scientific
quest for the Fountain of Youth this
field spans everything from the noble
quest to unravel incurable diseases like
Alzheimer's to work on reversing the age
of the body's organs well one man
millionaire entrepreneur Brian Johnson
has taken his quest to remarkable levels
he spent two million dollars working
with a team of 30 doctors and Medics to
effectively reboot his body and he
reckons he's managed to reverse his
biological age already by five years
you have to really think about it from a
holistic perspective so it's the common
things like diet and exercise but it's
also a much broader consideration so I
have a team of doctors that I work with
and we just go through this rigorous
process of measurement
gold standard science
implementation measurement is produced
near perfect health for me
sounds good doesn't it but in a moment
I'll talk to Brian Johnston but it's
worth considering why this might not be
about vanity or selfishness our
societies could depend on people being
healthier for longer in 1950 one in
every 12 people in the rich world was
aged 65 or above by 2050 it'll be closer
to one in four those old people are
expensive they'll need looking after and
that gets to the heart of the question
we're told the world's already
overpopulated that we can't feed or
House of people who already exist here
Mavericks like Brian Johnson have
resources and technologies that Ordinary
People don't meaning the process of
reversing aging is for now the preserver
the rich so could it actually be well
immoral to try to live longer can the
planet afford for him to be successful
in this Mission can we should we as I
asked at the start of a show try to turn
back time
well Brian Johnson uh joins me now Brian
great to have you on Piers Morgan and
censored before we get into your new
life and what you've been achieving or
not achieving I want to just take you
back to life before this you know you
grew up in Utah
um it was a very conventional American
Mormon life that you led and you became
uh in your 20s incredibly successful
carbonating in selling a business that
you created called Braintree Payment
Solutions to PayPal they're known by
eBay for 800 million dollars so for many
people it would have appeared that you
were living the American dream you were
a billionaire incredibly successful guy
and yet at the same time by your own
admission you were miserable you were
depressed to the point of feeling
suicidal you were very overweight you
were very stressed you've been through a
divorce and actually you thought your
life sucked
what was the Epiphany moment for you to
say right I'm going to do something
about this
I mean I learned how to fly an airplane
I got my pilot's license and one day I
was in the airplane and I was I had my
hands on the controls and I turned the
autopilot on and I was amazed at how the
autopilot was able to keep the plane
perfectly smooth even in turbulent air
and I wondered to myself could I build
an autopilot for me A system that takes
better care of me than I can and that's
when we started I wondered could we
could hire a team of doctors could we
look at scientific evidence uh create
scientific protocols and then iterate
that process again and again and
basically do exactly as the science and
data set and just have a system take
care of me and in that process I removed
my mind from the situation so I no
longer went to the pantry and try to
find food I didn't order off of menus at
restaurants I didn't go to the grocery
store and pick out what I thought looked
pretty it was just simply data science
and clinical grade protocols I got my
system running on its own
I mean it's it's completely fascinating
I think what you're doing here in terms
of the social experiment I guess my sort
of overview question is
how do you feel right now compared to
what you were like before that light
bulb moment
I don't think even if I could have
spoken to myself in that moment that I
could
fully articulate to myself what it would
feel like to be me right now the clarity
of mind the stability of emotions the
hope for life I've never felt this this
good in my entire life and it just is
really difficult to articulate a sense
of well-being
we're going to get to exactly how you've
been doing this but what was the overall
goal when you started out what was your
goal
I think we're at this really interesting
time in the early 21st century if we
zoom out on planet Earth and we try to
quiet all the noise everything going on
we try to say what really is going on I
would make three observations one is AI
is progressing at incredible speeds two
is the biosphere of our planet is
potentially in question and three we
humans are dangerously at each other's
throats and in the early 21st century if
we say Talent is the ability to hit the
target no one else can but genius is the
ability to hit the target no one can see
what is the genius move for us who live
in this early 21st century and it could
be changing our relationship with self
and with time we may think very
differently about ourselves as a species
about each other about war about
compassion and peace if this inevitable
decay in aging wasn't so omnipresent in
our minds in life
so Brian you're 45 years old now and yet
all the experts around you believe you
now have the heart of a 37 year old the
skin of a 28 year old the lung capacity
and fitness of an 18 year old and the
gum inflammation of a 17 year old so
regardless of anything else clearly you
are reversing the aging process on
specific parts of your body
yeah it appears I'd also say I think I
have the hope for the future of humanity
of an 18 year old
and I have an unbridled hope for the
future that I just don't think I've ever
had in my life
okay let's get into how you've done this
because one of the stats that leapt out
of me was just mind-boggling you've
taken 33
537 images of your bowels
is that true
that is true I smile I swallowed a
camera the size of a baby carrot and
then I took laxatives for six hours and
it came out 10 hours and 38 minutes
later yeah I'll Instagram worthy photos
laughs okay you discovered your
eyelashes are shorter than average you
probe the thickness of your carroted
artery and probably this will be of
interest to a lot of male viewers you
blasted your pelvic floor with
electromagnetic pulses to improve muscle
tone in those hard to reach areas of the
body
um and you believe this has had a
dramatically beneficial effect just on
your sexual function never mind anything
else
that's right yeah it had an off-target
uh result where I started experiencing
more and intense nighttime erections it
wasn't the intended target but it was a
a funny coincidence
so you are basically a human natural
Viagra machine
[Laughter]
I suppose so
um let's go through your day so you wake
up I think at five o'clock every morning
and you go to sleep I think religiously
at eight o'clock and we'll come to the
reasons why you're so specific about
that but when you get up what is the
first thing you do
my day consists of maybe 100 different
activities that we've designed
throughout the past two years every
activity I do is based upon scientific
evidence and a clinical grade protocol
so the first thing I do in the morning
is take my waking ear temperature my
body runs three degrees Fahrenheit lower
than normal so my morning temperature
reading is typically 95.9 or 96.1
Fahrenheit I then weigh myself looking
at a fat muscle body weight hydration I
get I have a special light for sunlight
exposure I then go downstairs drink a
concoction I call the green giant I take
57 pills and I didn't work out for an
hour I do red light therapy on my hair
HR HRV therapy heart rate variability
therapy via my ear and eat my breakfast
which is a few pounds of vegetables and
then I'm ready for the day and how much
actual exercise do you do like physical
exercise
it's an hour it's about uh just under 40
different movements I try to
flex and work every muscle in my entire
body
you you have remarkably low body fat I
think five to six percent is the average
you've been as low as three percent
which was considered dangerous and your
Medics had to do something about that I
mean are you concerned as you push it
and push it that you may push too far
yeah the body does need a certain amount
of fat what we did is we said I'm on
caloric restrictions so it's 2 000
calories a day the recommended daily
allowance for me is 2500 so I'm about 20
lower than normal a caloric restriction
has a lot a lot of scientific evidence
of being very beneficial I do that and
so the body with this 2000 calorie
budget I just let my body run and so we
keep very close track we have a whole
body MRI looking at fat muscle
throughout the whole body we use
ultrasound imaging we use other skills
so we track it very closely uh and it's
monitored the every measure modality we
can we can access
you're on a strict vegan diet
interestingly Bear Grylls the great
Adventurer recently came out with an
interview in which he said that he tried
a vegan diet for a while and actually
he's now pivoted to an organic meat diet
and believes the benefits from that are
much better for him I mean are you
convinced that a vegan diet is the only
way that you can achieve what you want
to achieve
I'm vegan by choice not by necessity
blueprint does not express any opinions
there's no human opinion in the entire
protocol we simply say we're going to
measure look at scientific evidence
create clinical grade protocols and do
the whole process again measurement
science data again and again and again
and so uh with me I prefer to be vegan
and so I've tried this out and it seems
to be working it does not say anything
about a carnivore diet people can
certainly do it and maybe achieve the
same outcomes I haven't done it but the
important thing is I have the 2 000
calories a day which I ate a lot of
vegetables but I also take you know 100
supplements that's not just to
accommodate veganism or caloric
restriction it's basically if you ask
every organ in the body and that's what
we try to do is measure every organ we
say hey heart hey kidney and lungs what
do you need to be your best self the
result is the diet and the
supplements I take so it really is a
body first when the body can speak
through data
what are the key supplements do you
think that you take every day
I have them here so this is for example
if you can see this this is 57 pills
that I take uh in the morning and then
this here is the remaining 35 or so that
I take in the afternoon and you know the
a lot of people look at that and say
that's that's extreme it is uh also it
is basically we are trying to ask a
question at the very Frontier of
scientific possibilities if you ask the
body what do you need to be an absolute
perfect health to slow the rate of Aging
to the maximum degree and try to reverse
aging that has happened that's our
question so it's not just how do you
maintain a healthy lifestyle it is
pushing the absolute Frontiers speaking
to the organs directly and so a lot of
people who try veganism or caloric
restriction they fail because they don't
account for the things they need in
terms of supplementing uh the things
they would otherwise Miss but you the
point is you with the data you can
verify whether these things can or
cannot work I take about four vitamins a
day supplements and quite often it take
takes me about three or four goes to get
it down my throat and sometimes I just
gag I think a lot of people have issues
taking pills you're taking nearly 100 a
day how do you actually physically do it
you do it in Big Big Lot blocks or what
do you do
yeah so this is the the drink I actually
have this is the the Green Giant
concoction and I can take the 50 plus
pills with about eight to ten ounces of
water all right it takes ounces of fluid
I guess I've just gotten very good at it
the the blueprint though this is this is
not an expectation that people are going
to begin taking 100 pills this is just
simply the statement to say if you
inquire the body via Frontier Medical
Science and you measure and use
scientific evidence what is possible in
the human body today there's a much
simpler version for people to do a home
that is repeatable for everybody
there's a guy called Jeff toll he's an
internal medicine expert on your team he
says I treat athletes and Hollywood
celebrities nobody is pushing the
envelope as much as Brian
and they say that the work so far has
made you five years younger from a
medical standpoint
um how far do you want to take this how
young do you want to try and get
yeah
you know the five-year age reversal I
think is interesting I'd say even more
impressive and exciting to me is if you
look at my speed of Aging how fast my
body actually ages it's my last
measurement uh was 0.69 which means I'm
now accumulating aging damage equal to
the average 10 year old now when we look
at a 10 year old we don't think they're
actually aging but they are we
accumulate aging damage throughout our
entire lives and the older we get the
faster we age and it compounds but I'm
now less than the average 10 year old
and so I guess one way of looking at it
in a humorous way is for every 12 months
that pass I get September October
November December for free because I age
so slowly right basically I've reduced
my speed of Aging by the equivalent of
31 years yeah it's absolutely
fascinating
um we're gonna take a short break Brian
when I come back I want to ask you I
guess a question many viewers might be
thinking was do you have any fun can you
eat fun stuff can you drink alcohol can
you can you do anything that's fun or is
it just this are you now a human robot
putting yourself Through Torture uh
we'll debate that after the break
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel no what
are you uh every little helps for God's
sake is nothing original anymore it's
finger licking Goods I'm loving it look
let's be honest we don't have any fancy
speech writers here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it well
that one too
[Music]
thank you
she won 18 grand slams and smashed every
barrier along the way two championship
points
and the dream has come true
[Applause]
she's never faced a battle like this
Martinez opens up on her devastating
double cancer diagnosis
a wide exclusive interview only on Piers
Morgan uncensored
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to a special edition of
Piers Morgan uncensored about whether
you can stop the aging process with
Brian Johnson is with me still
um Brian you've put up criticism of what
you're doing on social media it's been
very entertaining to read some of it
some of the examples of the of the
critiques you've received include Brian
you are surely miserable it would be
hilarious if Brian got hit by a bus LOL
I'd rather die than eat that kind of
stuff this is dystopic I wish you knew
my joy of pizza and donuts and the fact
you put it on your social media uh
indicates to me the other healthy
disregard for for trolls on social media
but I guess there's a serious point to
commit yourself to this kind of level of
extremity of health and fitness and diet
and so on
that does it leave much room for fun I
mean can you actually have any kind of
normal life
I mean first I love the trolls uh I just
get so much joy out of seeing their
their comments you can tell people put
in enormous amount of efforts to try to
make the most hurtful Zinger they can
yeah so I made the Brian Johnson hater
starter kit to share it so like you know
up your game don't use these things
other people have used but I mean the
the funny thing Piers is I I'm actually
happier I have more fun in life than I
ever have in my entire life and it just
is almost incomprehensible of people
they say if I can't drink later night
with friends and I can't stay out and I
can't eat my donuts and pizza or I can't
do these things I'm familiar with I
can't imagine an existence and I say I
can't imagine existing like that now I
absolutely am having the most fun I've
ever had in my entire life
okay do you drink alcohol
I don't
I presume you used to did you
I well for a while I drank three ounces
a day of red wine it was 74 calories it
was just too expensive for my caloric
budget so uh it's I just don't have the
caloric budget to include it so you've
never really been a drinker so that
hasn't been for you a personal sacrifice
to have to stop all together
that's right never was a thing for me
okay so what about treats Sweet Treats
chocolates you know cake stuff like that
can you have that
I eat 15 grams so it's a tablespoon of
100 dark chocolate a day and if you want
to really get you know wild then I'll
add some Manuka honey and some trejolos
but that's about it I don't go to my
prince my pantry I don't peruse around
uh if you are in my house and you're
feeling naughty there's just not there's
really nothing to do so no I I just
don't miss those things in fact doing it
it just imagine doing it just makes me
sick I just can't imagine uh
eating that kind of stuff you see it's
interesting because I've been on a bit
of a health kick and the the most
difficult thing I'm sure everyone feels
this if you're used to a certain way of
life you get to my age you know late 50s
is it's how do you do that how do you
discipline yourself
to only have that one little bit of
chocolate I'm getting better at it
actually the more you do it the easier
it is obviously yeah
um but it's interesting that you don't
you don't deprive yourself completely
then you you are allowed little treats
you just everything in very strict
moderation
that's right the key thing is I've
eliminated my choice I fired my mind I
joke uh playfully refer to this as
firing evening Brian this is between the
5 PM 10 p.m Brian who the former version
of me would eat excessively of the worst
kind of food and I was 60 pounds heavier
than I am now and he just made my life
miserable and I fired him one day and
just said you no longer have decision
control you cannot eat food no matter
what and this program with blueprint I
basically said I will follow the
scientific evidence and the data I do
not have Choice ever if I go to a
restaurant I cannot choose if I go to
The Pantry I cannot choose because I
know if I give myself the slightest
window of choice I'm gonna mess it up
unquestionably my mind is going to do
the wrong thing I mean that says to me
you've got a very strong willpower
unusually strong
uh yeah it's taken me a couple years to
build this up the key thing though is
you know we oftentimes think of our
minds as our very best tool to solve the
most complicated problems in reality and
in this case my mind was my worst enemy
it was the thing that was preventing me
from actually being my best self and it
is a rascal I mean it is uncontrollable
it is Relentless the moment I let it
back in my life it destroys me so it's
really been this eye-opening experience
for me that my mind has a particular
place in in my conscious existence but
for the majority of decision making it's
really a terrible thing to have how much
time can you allocate per day for work I
mean you're still an entrepreneur you're
still involved in some very big uh Tech
businesses in particular how much time
do you devote to work a day
I mean I guess I've been an entrepreneur
in my my entire life I'm accustomed to
having multiple full-time jobs so
blueprint is just it's a full-time job
uh intermixed with everything else I do
I'm a founder and CEO of companies of
tech companies and so it's all just one
big fluid movement I have a great team
around me so we do a lot of things
simultaneously uh I it's a really nice
structure and I guess I I think of
myself I'm I'm not a biohacker I'm not
trying to be a health hobbyist I'm a
professional Rejuvenation athlete and so
a lot of people look at my lifestyle
they say that's really weird it's
because they're comparing it to a you
know a person in the 20th early 21st
century if you were to look at the
practices of LeBron James you wouldn't
say oh that's weird he goes to bed on
time and eats really well and does this
kind of strength training you respect
what he does in the court and so the
same thing is with me I'm a professional
Rejuvenation athlete and my lifestyle
reflects that how important is sleep to
you because you go to bed I think On A
Clockwork at eight o'clock regardless of
whatever you're doing if you're watching
a movie or having a conversation
whatever 8 o'clock bank that's it in
into bed and asleep why so important and
how many hours do you need
yeah sleep is the number one most
important priority in my entire life the
difference between hope and despair is a
good night's sleep you get sleep right
everything else becomes possible and so
I typically am in bed around nine nine
and a half hours I wear a whoop which is
a wearable on my wrist and uh recently I
was talking to the founder and we were
just playfully looking at data we pulled
up my data and I was in the 99.2
percentile for Sleep Quality I didn't
realize how I compared to uh people
doing that but yeah I take sleep very
seriously and it really is the fuel of
my life I mean I think most people who
hear that will will know that's true and
if I have a good night's sleep I'm I
perform on a completely different level
so if I have a night of broken sleep and
feel tired it's just a that is something
I think every human knows uh how do you
get better sleep you have to do
everything that you're doing to be able
to get your nine hours
I mean it's just a few Basics one is you
treat sleep like a lighthouse it's never
negotiated away it can never be delayed
it can never be the thing you just push
away because you have a late night or
homework or you're with friends it
happens at the same time every night no
matter what I watch very closely what I
eat so I have about eight to ten hours
of fasting before I go to bed so my body
I have a low resting heart rate I have a
blocked out room I sleep by myself which
is a luxury I have a lot of people don't
have that option I have a temperature
controlled mattress which is also great
but I really have dialed this in over
two years it's a system and I I get a
high quality sleep every single night
it's something I do I didn't before I
mean having three little kids and
building a company and going you know
having a difficult relationship like
it's not having good sleep just makes
life miserable what do your kids make of
it particularly the one I think one of
your sons is 17 so nearly the age that
you're trying to turn yourself into 18.
what do they make of this are they
supportive do it gets all a bit weird
yeah it's funny one of my my 17 year old
he used to take this super veggie
actually here it is uh this is what what
I ate for breakfast it's uh cauliflower
broccoli lunch black lentils mushrooms
garlic and ginger and he took this to
school lunch with him every day his
friends were eating Doritos pizza and
drinking soda and he ripped out these
two pounds of vegetables and one of his
friends tweeted out I don't know what's
going on with this guy at home but I
hope everything's all right no just kind
of playing around but it just called
attention to that it was so weird that
he was eating this a few pounds of
vegetables at school lunch when everyone
else had their stuff but he's fully into
it and he's such a good uh uh sport
anytime we do anything new he's jumping
in to measure himself or do it so he
loves it and his friends I think have
different opinions they see it's unusual
they admire it they like it they ask
questions if they are curious so I mean
it it's a different thing from popular
accustomed to seeing what about love and
romance Brian because you've been
through a divorce so clearly that was
non-successful relationship in the end
um can you have a relationship if you're
doing all this I mean I don't quite see
how you would fit a woman into his life
yeah that's a legitimate question and
I'm still trying to sort that out uh
when I do engage I do clearly
communicate here's the system here's the
program here's what I'm trying to do
here's where the openings are and you
know it's a pretty narrow set of
potential mates because uh what I do is
pretty rigorous uh This plus the other
endeavors and so I would say some people
really get it other people you know it's
not conducive to them so I'd say that's
the thing I need to figure out within
the next version of blueprint I mean no
disrespect but I don't think Valentine's
Day would be a barrel of last with you
would it
hahaha
well you would be surprised Bears I mean
we do really fun things so we we we did
chocolate covered berries with trehills
and Manuka honey we danced around and
had a celebration so a lot of people
think this is misery it's not we
actually I think we have more fun than
most people do I mean obviously you know
having earlier established that your
sexual function performance is clearly
enhanced now it does seem a bit of a
waste
that's a good point we should put that
to use
what I like about you Brian is from what
I can see you're not trying to fleece
the public you're not trying to scam
people by saying you give me twenty
thousand dollars and you can be like me
you're just spending your money doing
this for yourself and you want to share
this with people and just show them what
happens
that's right and it's also the case that
when I mean we all health and wellness
is a lot like religion I mean uh with
the Bible hundreds of religions are
robustly supported saying they're
they're God's true and only and the same
is kind of true with health and wellness
that there's so many different things
you can do for health and wellness and
no one really knows what's true so most
people look at it and say like I don't
know does anything even matter and what
we're trying to do with blueprint is to
say we're going to create the number one
best wellness program ever created in
history and we're going to do it with
data now if somebody wants to beat us
with data amazing now the public has two
options to choose from what we're trying
to do is Pierce through the noise and
say there is there are options that are
better better than others and blueprint
is not to say it's the only option it's
a version but we're trying to create
this competitive disposition that if you
want to be in a game of Health and
Wellness
show the data the results are the only
thing that matter and so hopefully this
is a helpful thing for everybody to say
I want to be better I want to start
doing things what do I do well now
there's an example for you everything's
freely shared with everybody but you
ultimately think that you can prove that
you can reverse the aging process or are
you just going to be so super fit and
healthy that you can arrest the rate of
decline
I mean I grew up reading biographies I
read hundreds of biographies and I my
favorite thing is reading about people
who in their time and place in whatever
Century they lived they were able to
identify an impossibly hard thing and go
after that thing that was outside the
Zeitgeist at the time and place when
they showed it was possible Society runs
with it so really I think the question
here is if we can show that dramatically
slowing your rate of Aging is possible
and even reversing it it's going to kick
off a whole ecosystem of Endeavors and
what we've shown so far with just two
years of efforts dramatically slowing my
speed of agent by 31 years now
accumulating agent damage less than a 10
year old five years of age reversal 50
perfect biomarkers is compelling these
are just the basics we haven't even
gotten to the more advanced therapy so I
think it is a big shift in the Zeitgeist
that it is here and now and the more
advanced therapies are just coming
online right now well it's absolutely
riveting to listen to this I've got to
say and I think everyone will will
resonate with at least what you're
trying to achieve and would love to
think this can work Brian thank you for
your time we're going to spend the next
15 minutes now debating what you've been
telling me but uh thank you for sharing
it it's really interesting
thank you for having me bears
well there you have it one remarkable
man's quest to turn back the clock and
you've got to say looking at him and
listening to him he seems well adjusted
happy ridiculously fit very healthy
what's not to love I'll be joined after
the break by an expert panel to get
their thoughts on Brian Johnson and this
potential reversal of the aging process
is it possible or should we just all
grow old gracefully or disgracefully
we'll be back in a few minutes
[Music]
thank you we're leading Britain's
conversation oh no with the people's
Channel nowhere to use every little
helps for God's sake is nothing original
anymore it's finger licking Goods I'm
loving it look let's be honest we don't
have any fancy speech writers here but
we do and I promise you discuss the
issues that matter to you yes I'm back
talk TV not with Morgan just before him
Monday to Thursday at 7pm join me just
do it what that one too
[Music]
thank you foreign
18 Grand Slams have smashed every
barrier along the way to Championship
points
and the dream has come true
[Applause]
which is never faced a battle like this
Martinez ratalova opens up on her
devastating double cancer diagnosis
a wide exclusive interview only on Piers
Morgan uncensored
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Phelps on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
this is talk TV
thank you
[Music]
welcome back I've just been doing a
quick session in the gym and the
commercial break there trying to get
myself in shape
um remarkable interview there with the
45 year old Tech entrepreneur Brian
Johnson on his quest to turn back the
clock to 18. it's clearly a very
punishing regime he clearly rather
enjoys doing him is it all worth it for
joining me now Dr Nyla Raja known as the
queen of Botox Dr Oliver Zolman who's
worked extensively with Brian Johnson on
his anti-aging project and the Green
Goddess herself Diana Moran a picture of
blooming Health as always awesome with
me a professor Lord Robert Winston and
biologist Gary Brecker so an All-Star
panel here Lord Winston I was in the
corner of my eye seeing you rolling your
eyes at some of that interview what is
your overview of what you've just been
listening to
well I wasn't rolling my eyes I had my
eyes shut actually
um I'm sorry I'm sorry that I can't see
you I spent some of the time sleeping
because of course this is the sort of
message we've been hearing
from snake oil salesman for the last 250
years and there's nothing new here there
are various things which certainly can
improve your chances of living longer
exercise better diet not smoking and so
on but actually the evidence of by the
way peers don't take extra vitamins it's
a complete waste of time there's no
evidence at all there are no data to
support that claim and I think you
should know that because if you have
difficulty swallowing them your body is
telling you something don't swallow them
and you're probably right is that right
you really think all vitamins are always
no of course no no vitamins are not a
waste of time but actually virtually
everybody who has a normal diet will be
taking enough vitamins that the body
actually needs right there are a few
exceptions but but in fact you know we
all get enough they all get enough
vitamin C enough vitamin D clearly if we
live in the dark we weren't but with a
few exceptions all those vitamins that
I've taken in vitamin pills are
completely unnecessary and do not
actually affect your aging process
and there's good scientific evidence to
support that
the medical team around him believe he
now has the heart of a 37 year old the
skin of a 28 year old a lung capacity
and fitness of an 18 year old and the
gum inflammation of a 17 year old and
much better sexual performance he
believes yes are all those things are
they all impossible I I heard that
I heard that you know what he's also got
the intellectual capacity of a 10 year
old as well because and that's that's
the problem
and you know actually let's be serious
these claims for different markers
biomarkers as he calls them are just
simply not there they're not
substantiated you know in in the sounds
and Technologies like committee which I
sit on which looked at the aging process
and published our report only last year
to the government we showed that there
were there were a few markers none of
which are being measured in these people
and the real and there's a real issue
here which is actually quite important
that is if you I've just come back from
a part of Wales where the average
longevity is about 10 years less than it
is for example where you and I live in
in the Richer parts of London and the
fact of the matter of course is that the
biggest problem we have in our society
is deprivation we have actually serious
problems in living conditions in work
and poverty and these actually really
shorten lifespan and there is good
evidence to do that and really if we
were really wanting to do something
important about longevity we should be
looking at deprivation in our community
and looking at education in our
community but not wasting our time with
snake oil
substitutes for actually proper living
of course he's right you can live
properly but actually taking minuscule
amounts of food in the way that he's
suggesting I didn't hear the whole
interview but I heard enough to know
that actually there is no proven
evidence good scientific data he keeps
on quoting data but actually he doesn't
actually publish those data because he
doesn't actually have the data and the
data are available and sadly you know
it's a Pity because you know there is an
important subject here people are dying
too soon people are aging too soon but
they're aging really because of the
environment in which they're living and
that's a big problem or we should be
doing more about it okay we could do
much more about it and as a promise
promise the government made actually but
in fact it turns out that longevity in
Britain over the last 10 years has
actually shortened rather than
lengthened right that's a real problem
yeah no there's a problem let me go to
Dr Oliver Zolman Oxford regenerative
physician you work on the team of Brian
Johnson pretty damning verdict there
from Lord Winston who's very eminent in
his field your response oh it's it's not
that I mean you know it's very
reasonable
um you know it's all experimental what
we're doing and there's a lot of
mistakes in some of the media as well uh
some of the articles that come out
so as always with science and
experimentation and research you only
want to rely on peer-reviewed scientific
evidence
of these results so we're starting to
publish these results this year in
peer-reviewed journals and any numbers
other than that I wouldn't believe
um because there's a lot of mistakes in
the in the media basically says this is
all just snake oil stuff you know you
just it's just it's a scam really it's
it's not based on scientific reality
yeah so we have clinical guidelines that
we write for each marker and these are
all experimental clinical guidelines
which are peer reviewed by World experts
in each area so you know for a kidney
Rejuvenation we're looking at bringing
all the best kidney doctors that are
experiencing that researchers as well so
phds MDS everyone
um but yeah for results we're proving
Rejuvenation results at n equals one
it's very tricky by statistically it's
easier in population studies or large
randomized controlled trials so wait for
the peer-reviewed Publications
um and get involved in peer review as
well okay do we bring in Dr Nala Roger
Botox is your thing or the botox Queen
so you you specialize in making people
look younger artificially if you like
cosmetically what do you make of Brian
Johnson
um
some of the studies
I mean there are some studies that show
that that you can actually improve the
um you know the epigenetic age of
someone the problem is that the cohort
studies are so small that they're not
statistically significant obviously I
run a chain of cosmetic clinics and I
can show that phenotypically I can
definitely improve your your appearance
actually you couldn't improve this no no
you tried there's no amount of money in
the world that could improve it and of
course with the right skin care I have
obviously a skincare collection which
can obviously make you look a lot better
it can make you look I'm actually an 82
percentile so I did a documentary in Los
Angeles a plastic surgeon computer
printed my face I said my skin quality
was in the top 18 of all men in
California of my age which given what
they slap on their faces I took us a
massive bonus and I suspect it's two
things I don't smoke yeah other than the
very odd cigar and secondly genetics on
my mother's side in particular the women
all lived in yeah be nearly 100 so it's
a genetic thing they all had good skin
yeah of course yeah and lifestyle as
well that's really important
um I think there is as a doctor
obviously we will tell all of our
patients did anything he's saying make
you think you can reverse the aging
process
um
I think it is good Medical Practice what
he's you know it's a bit extreme what
he's saying but I think obviously if you
can tell people to live a diet which is
healthy nutritious and the lifestyle
which is much more you know obviously it
includes exercise then obviously then
you can improve your overall life span
let me bring them in look you're known
to to Britain as a a goddess of fitness
and health and everything
is what he's doing really anything more
different than just an extreme view of
what you were doing
I really am quite amazed with what I've
heard let's put it that way to start
with good or bad
probably on the bad really why
um why does one want to stop the aging
process well maybe he's enjoying his
life and wants to hang around a bit
longer but
some of us who have aged
you're
basically the female Benjamin Button but
but
that I can't see anything wrong with
aging as the years have gone would you
like to if you could reverse it no way
go back to 18 Again positively no way
I'd love to be 18. I I would not my
mother had just died I came home from
school and found her dead
um I took on the role of the family so
it was actually a difficult period mine
was a very difficult I cannot see why
everybody is worrying about aging I'm
loving aging you talked earlier on about
aging gracefully or disgracefully I'm
quite happy to do the disgrace for him
as well and
um my life is I work hard and I've had
my own personal problems with the cancer
and all sorts of other things but I love
life I could show you hundreds of my
well let's say 50 of my friends all of
similar age we're loving life for those
with my mum and dad at the weekend and
they are fantastic plastic form we went
out for dinner and they're on great form
my dad's in his early 80s my mom in her
late 70s but I think if I gave them the
chance to try and reverse it they'd both
jump at it are you sure yes I think so
my dad my dad would love to be back in
his 30s running nightclubs in the south
of the France he would have loved it
but you see the thing is that when you
get I'm in my 80s as well as you know my
middle 80s and you've got to this are
you really yes
I've seen um you're like the female
Brian Johnson are you doing it in a
different way and I've done it very
naturally right very very naturally I've
never had any of the nip and Tuck
nothing whatsoever that's probably why
you look so good no offense but there's
always the women who don't do that to
their faces end up looking great but I
was listening I was listening to the
doctor talking about supplements and
likes of basically if we're eating a
good diet you get enough got enough you
take any supplements at all I take a
supplement for vitamin A vitamin D I
don't get the sunshine because I had
skin cancer right can't sit in the Sun
Well Joan Collins who's 189 and looks
amazing too hasn't been out in the sun
directly since she was 21. and she puts
that extreme as that yeah but possibly
for the last 20 years would you go out
but it's always wears a white hat and
all that I want to bring in human
biologists Gary Brecker Gary used to
work for an insurance company could
predict when people would die based on
blood and DNA which sounds a very morbid
occupation I have to be honest um what
do you make of this what do you make of
Brian Johnson we've heard the expert
view from Lord Winston who just thinks
it's all hogwash and snake oil stuff
what do you think
I think it's amazing I think it's
amazing I think he's spot on um I would
disagree with the previous guest that um
uh you know aging is is not a disease
that we can control we know that aging
is the aggressive pursuit of comfort
um the more aggressively we pursue
Comfort the faster we age you know we
know that if we don't load our bones
they don't strengthen if we don't tear
our muscles they don't grow if we don't
challenge the immune system it weakens
and without data and we generally have
data on our businesses but we have no
data on ourselves I mean most of us that
run a business have our income statement
our balance sheet our p and hell but we
know nothing about what's going on
inside our bodies we don't know our
hormone balance or glycemic control or
nutrient deficiencies and there's hordes
of published clinical evidence all
throughout the peer-reviewed literature
um in in in very renowned
journals that supports things like
nutrient deficiencies blood sugar
control hormone balance as being the
consequence of advanced aging and when
we talk about environmental factors the
Environmental factors are what lead to
deficiencies you see most of the
consequences that we accept as aging
things like brain fog poor sleep weight
gain water retention poor response to
exercise poor Delta wave of sleep these
are not consequences of Aging
um at all there are actually
consequences consequences of nutrient
deficiencies in the body and unless we
test and we know what nutrients our body
can convert and what it can't by genetic
testing unless we look at our blood work
and we see where our hormone balance
lies how well we're controlling our
blood sugar what nutrient deficiencies
are causing us to have maladies that
we're associating with aging but are
actually associated with deficiencies in
the human body then we're just running
blind um we're eating for the sake of
eating we're seeking Comfort we're
trying to control our environment we're
trying to control our uh the temperature
you know in my opinion we we have to
stop telling Grandma not to go outside
it's too hot not to go outside it's too
cold to to just lay down to just relax
just eat at the very first Pang of
hunger this is collapsing all of our
natural defense mechanisms things like
cold water exposure
photobiomodulation which is taking the
healing energy from the Sun and bringing
it indoors breath work contacting the
surface of the Earth so you'll basically
that's sort of interrupt uh we're
running running a bit short on time but
just to summarize you basically think
there's a lot of Merit in what he's
doing
oh there's extreme Merit in what he's
doing I mean when you're optimizing
things like hormone balance nutrient
deficiencies and glycemic control how
well we control our blood sugar
you're you're talking about a
substantial extension in life
um you know I would say that
um you know blood sugar is the root of
all evil secondary second to
inflammation
um you know there's there's links now
between uh type 3 diabetes insulin
resistance in the brain and early onset
Alzheimer's and Dementia and all sorts
of neurodegenerative disorders and and
that's very you know very well
documented it's it's widely available
and peer-reviewed published
um journals okay and I think that people
that are seeking to to live longer
should get data on their body and
respond to that data okay well little
Winston no Winston medically he wants to
see some proper Data before he's
prepared to accept any of this which I
think is completely happy to send it to
you Winston well Lord Winston now should
we call him over here he's a pair of the
realm um thank you thank you to all my
panel it's been fascinating to hear all
the range of views it's certainly an
interesting discussion Point
um I think people will be gripped by
this either way but advice you can't
always call just eat a bit out there you
know do a bit more exercise not drink as
much alcohol put enough toxins in your
face you probably would end up living a
bit longer so there are natural ways to
do this without actually becoming a
human robot but we'll see thank you to
my panel all very much and to you Lord
Winston as well thank you very much well
until next time some big news about the
latest Piers Morgan are sent to the
exclusives which are coming off next
week two big interviews with big people
[Music]
thank you we're leading Britain's
conversation oh no with the people's
Channel no we're gonna use every little
helps for God's sake is nothing original
anymore it's finger licking Goods I'm
loving it look let's be honest we don't
have any fancy speech writers here but
we do and I promise you discuss the
issues that matter to you yes I'm back
talk TV not with Morgan just before him
Monday to Thursday at 7pm join me just
do it what that one too
[Music]
thank you
she won 18 grand slams and smashed every
barrier along the way
to Championship points
and the dream has come true
[Applause]
she's never faced a battle like this
Martinez opens up on her devastating
double cancer diagnosis
a wide exclusive interview only on Piers
Morgan uncensored
[Music]
foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Felts is
on talk TV every night of the week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
foreign
next week on Piers Morgan uncensored
with some big name interviews from very
different spheres of Life on Monday I'll
be sitting down for a one-on-one for the
whole show with Richard Dawkins probably
one of the most well controversial
polemists in the world take a look at
this
what was that at the start what do you
think happens when you die but your
certain is not a God and yet you admit
you don't know and you're a very
vehement atheist no I'm not you're
provoking me to be the other because
you're taking that tone with me I get
that but but I don't think you do get it
at the bottom of the garden and all
sorts of things are possible you're
being accused of being an islamophobe
are you you yourself compared Trump to
Hitler well stuff of a horror film isn't
it
as Richard Dawkins 101 on Monday and
later in the week a world exclusive
interview with Martina Navratilova the
tennis champion who's been battling two
cancers throat cancer and breast cancer
in the last few months now she's going
to talk for the first time about what
she's been through it should be a very
emotional interview that's Martina
Navratilova later next week take a look
at this
she won 18 grand slams and smashed every
barrier along the way two championship
points
[Applause]
which he's never faced a battle like
this Martin and rattle over opens up on
her devastating double cancer diagnosis
a word exclusive interview only on Piers
Morgan uncensored
[Music]
for tune in next week I'll be the wrong
censored all week for some big
interviews that's it for us tonight to
Keep It Uncensored good night
[Music]
thank you
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel note
what are you uh every little helps for
God's sake is nothing original anymore
it's finger licking good I'm loving it
look let's be honest we don't have any
fancy speech writers here but we do and
I promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it what
that one too
[Music]
thank you
so 118 Grand Slams have smashed every
barrier along the way two championship
points
and the dream has come true
[Applause]
she's never faced a battle like this
Martinez opens up on her devastating
double cancer diagnosis